President Trump is strongly resisting
congressional Democrats who want to see
his financial data and question current
and former White House aides the
president told The Washington Post his
staffers should not testify on Capitol
Hill he says they have cooperated fully
with Special Counsel robert muller and
quote there is no reason to go any
further especially in congress where it
is very partisan the House Judiciary
Committee has sent a subpoena for
testimony from former White House
Counsel Don McGann a crucial witness in
the Moller investigation widget Jang is
at the White House we show good morning
good morning Nora president Trump's new
comments come as a senior administration
official tells CBS News the White House
is keeping all of its legal options open
in regard to any subpoena served on a
former or current administration
official former White House Counsel Don
Magan is mentioned more than 150 times
in the Moller report Magan recounted in
detail to investigators how the
President ordered him to fire special
counsel robert muller and then pressured
him to deny that ever happened
president Trump is accusing House
Democrats of trying to score political
points telling the Washington Post I
allowed my lawyers and all the people to
go and testify to Muller I could have
taken the absolute opposite route House
Judiciary Committee Chairman Jerry
Nadler says the moment for the White
House to assert some privilege to
prevent this testimony from being heard
has long since passed all of this comes
amid escalating tension between the
administration and Congress Treasury
secretary Stephen minuchin defied a
second demand from House Democrats to
turn over the president's tax returns
john louisa thank you of course Don
Magan said he's the White House lawyer
he's not the president's lawyer and
that's one of the important distinction